and it's really like uh you know it's
like a it's like a horror movie scenario
right it's like Lord of the Rings really
and so Sauron is is trying to build a
body for himself like he's not
completely incarnate but he is he's
using all these people's desire for
power in order to create a body for
himself you know that's pretty much what
it looks like is happening with this AI
which is that we're all we're all
running towards a cliff we all know
we're running towards a cliff
[Music]
good
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
it's interesting because often I talk
about things and I talk to you guys
about certain subjects
uh but then when they come in the news
it's as if I don't really feel like
talking about it anymore
I don't know why I'm like that but
that's kind of how I am and so
everybody's telling me you know you need
to talk about AI you need to talk about
AI
and uh my reaction in some ways is that
you know I've been talking to you guys
for years about AI you know and I've
been saying things like if you want to
understand what a fallen angel is
pay attention to AI for years literally
and so now that the entire thing is
exploding
um
you know I don't know why I hesitate to
talk about it but I will talk about it
and I'll talk about it through one
interesting tack which is
um you know someone called attention for
me to what they call the moloch
alignment uh problem and to be honest I
never heard of this issue it's a it's
something in Game Theory it's kind of a
scenario in Game Theory and uh it's
interesting first of all it's called
moloch it's based on a Ginsburg poem
uh and basically it's the idea in some
ways that technology has a a will of its
own you could say and it seems to have a
kind of agency that uh that no one can
stop like no one can act against and you
know the people that are are behind this
uh this notion of agency I don't know if
they totally see it as a full agency or
if they just see it as a kind of
Illusion of Agents or mock agency but in
the end it doesn't really matter does it
because it's definitely experienced as a
kind of agency in the same way that you
would experience individually something
on you that you can't totally control
you know a force or a process in your
own behavior like an addiction or
something like that that you can't stop
that you can tell the person why don't
you just stop you know why don't you
just stop smoking why don't you just
stop doing whatever it is that you're
doing that's a d That's that that you're
addicted to uh but for some reason they
get caught in this in this agency and so
it's interesting uh because the way that
the moloch problem lays itself out is
that you know there are certain there's
a certain setup and the person in the uh
in the paper that there the article that
uh talked about it
um I forget his name I'll link to it in
the description he uses the arms race as
an example of this which I've used you
know when I talked about basically The
Book of Enoch my video in the Book of
Enoch I talk about the the idea that the
arms race is a good example of noticing
agency in the world uh transpersonal
agency that you can't stop right that
it's like you can you know why don't we
all just stop this and it's like okay
why don't you do that you know it just
doesn't work that way uh and so this is
of course what's happening with AI
and so what's happening is that people
are in a kind of arms race where they
can't stop the protest in that
everybody knows that by making it happen
they are making let's say they're making
the situation worse in terms of let's
say Humanity but they also know that
whoever doesn't do it will be in the
worst position of all the others and so
you know the fact that everybody knows
that now that AI is kind of out of the
box and is Unleashed whoever isn't on
board with AI will fall at the end of
the line and whoever is on board with AI
although although they know that they
might
pretty sure they're making the world the
worst place and a more and a more uh you
know a more chaotic place and also a
place where there'll be more control
those two things at the same time uh
they also know that they have to do it
or else their competitors whether it's a
direct com whether it's a competitor
like another company or whether it's a
competitor like a country let's say like
China uh they have no choice because if
we do we want China to be in control of
AI like no we want to be in control of
AI because we don't trust the Chinese
but then we also do we trust Microsoft
to be in control of AI and so it's been
very fascinating to see the recent
developments most of you will probably
have seen the interview uh that Elon
Musk did with Tucker Carlson where he he
straight up said that the head of Google
you know knew that he was wanting to
create a God and when Elon Musk objected
too much
um
the head of Google said that he was
speciesist and you know it's very
interesting to see that it's so
fascinating to notice that
you know where the move whereas now
we're seeing it almost clearly right
where it is that the desire to grab
power leads to and so if you try to to
grab power for yourself like in a
revolutionary manner right the
Promethean idea that you just grab power
for yourself Adam and Eve taking the
Apple for themselves you know it seems
like what It ultimately leads to is a
desire to be
overturned they desire to die a desire
to be overrun by something that will do
the same to you you know I've often felt
like uh you know in some of the myths
it's it's it's manifested as
trying to stop it right so if you see in
the myth of uh Zeus he tries to stop his
father from from eating him you know he
tries to stop I think no it's not Zoo
sorry it's Kronos and you know he he
kills his father so then he eats his
children and to stop them from
Revolution from you know coming up
against him and in some ways Zeus does
the same you see he does the same with
Prometheus right Prometheus tries to
takes the fire he ties him to uh you
know to the to a wall and has a eagle
eat his liver every day uh but it seems
like there's an even more perverse part
which is almost a desire to be upended a
desire to die it's like a death desire I
don't know how else to describe it
um and so that's very fascinating to
watch with the question of AI
um but this idea that the agency that
people are noticing in terms of not just
the AI but the way that AI is acting on
us in a larger scale that is the agency
of AI is not just the agency of the AI
itself it's the man pattern which it's
acting on us and the fact that it is in
some ways working to its own birth right
let's say and it's really like uh you
know it's like a it's like a horror
movie scenario right it's like uh it's
like Lord of the Rings really and so
Sauron is is trying to build a body for
himself like he's not completely
incarnate but he is he's using he's
using all these people's uh desire for
power uh in order to to to create a body
for himself you know that's pretty much
what it looks like is happening uh with
this AI which is that we're all we're
all running towards a cliff we all know
we're running towards a cliff
um
but in some ways it's almost like as if
we're pushing others towards the cliff
and we know that unless we push someone
else will push us over the cliff so we
think we might as well push everybody
else over the cliff so we're the last
ones to fall uh but that seems like
that's what that's what's happening but
it's interesting to notice that it the
image of a demon is used to you know
they demit the image of moloch you know
to whom the children were sacrificed is
used to image that and I think that
that's not a coincidence because
ultimately what we're seeing is agency
and so that's what's that's important to
understand is that the agency of AI we
try to limit it to the AI itself and ask
ourselves is it is it does it have
Consciousness does it have agency you
know all of that Etc et cetera there's a
way on which AI has agency over us which
is outside of the software right it's
not it's not it's outside of the program
it's the very way in which we're
developing AI which is showing that it's
manifesting a principality you know
because its power is not limited by the
is not limited by the software it's not
limited by open AI or Chad GPT or any of
the other people competing it is
literally acting on us from Beyond that
and the Very way in which we're building
its body is part of its agency over us
uh and so I think that at that point
it's very difficult to not see it as
different types of agency and and then
of course in the AI itself you know this
kind of movement towards
towards it becoming a type of agency on
us that also seems to be inevitable but
I also really do believe that
there's a way in which it's not agency
it's not an it's not the AI again that's
that has the agency it's something
Beyond it it's something that is
manipulating it
um and I think that that's the most
important you know most of the types of
AI that are succeeding right now
they're not uh strict AIS they're
something we could call like hybrid AIS
where
like we talked about with Dr Paula
boddington what they're doing is that
actually they're farming intelligence so
the eye doesn't have intelligence the AI
is power right the AI is is very much
um yeah it's the best way to understand
it it's power and the agency is us and
so the best image to understand that is
to understand the story of the Genie's
lamp now I've alluded to this story
several times but the the level to which
it corresponds to what's happening right
now is very important to meditate upon
now
take the elements of the of the Genie's
lamp so the the lamp is technology
that's what it is a lamp is a way to
have light at night right it's a way for
you to continue to have light when there
shouldn't be light so it's an increase
in your power to have light now
the the interesting thing about the lamp
in particular it doesn't have to be
sometimes it's a bottle sometimes it's a
ring sometimes it's all kind of
technical objects that increase your
power but the lamp is particularly
because it's light and so in some ways
it is closer to what AI is doing that is
it is an artificial way to perceive the
world it is it is an artificial light
it's a it's a it's a frame of vision
it's a something which is projecting uh
light on surfaces that is artificial and
so we see it framed we can we're
starting to see with the frame of
technology and so it's much closer to
what AI is now
but with the AI really what what the
genie offers is simply power it simply
increase in power and what it needs is a
reason it needs a purpose it needs a
wish it needs a direction and so we are
the ones that provide the direction and
so the genie appears as this infinite
power
couched in technology that now is just
waiting for you to tell it where to
point and once you do then you get what
you ask for with all the power of the
genie and so
this is of course uh you know so it's
not just it's not just a simple morality
tale it's something like uh you know
it's something like
all the power if you if you take
something if you direct if you have a
direction if it's not the right
direction if it's not god let's say so
imagine someone asks the genie uh you
know what if if the genie says what it
is that you want I can grant you three
wishes now imagine if someone's in
something like I want like what
um what Solomon says I want wisdom
I want uh I want to love others I want
true knowledge right and not in the
sense of artificial but let's say
knowledge of the good let's say
something like that that would be very
different now all of a sudden there
would be there would be uh fewer ways
that the genie could
that the G the answer of the genie could
go wrong the problem is that we ask for
secondary goods and all those secondary
Goods have side effects and so if we
become hyper efficient and and you know
we increase the power to do anything by
a million then all the side effects of
that will appear inevitably because
they're not because it's you're putting
all the power towards something which is
secondary and so it's an image of sin
itself right it's an image of Pride
itself it's it's an image of all these
things uh and so that is of course the
difficulty with AI is that it is now
going to offer
in you know almost near infinite power
being directed in any kind of Direction
in any direction we wish and so what
that will bring is of course a kind of
Chaos
which will lead to
authoritarian an authoritarian answer
right that that seems to be
how this is going to end uh and if you
if you follow Mets here on Twitter if
you don't you should because he's he's
basically going he's going scorched
Earth on us on us uh so be attentive
because he's gonna he's gonna say things
that are gonna be more and more
mysterious but more and more important
to uh to understand uh you know he
retweeted a video of uh someone using
the uh some video game to make a point
about AI which is that what AI will do
is lead to uh centralized control and
that is almost inevitable because of the
infinite power and Chaos that it's
unleashing and so if you go you know I
started following what's his name Sam
Altman the head of openai on Twitter
and I went to his Twitter page and I
noticed that he is advocating for
centralized digital ID and at first I
was like why is he pushing for digital
ID you know what does that have to do
with open Ai and then I realized very
quickly that
it has very much to do with AI because
the situation we're in is that within a
few months you'll get a phone call
and you'll have no way to know if it's
the person the right person call you
you'll get and you'll get you'll see a
picture you won't know if it's real
they'll be all you'll the will have no
way to discern
what is truth and what is is fiction
um and so
the only way to do that will be to give
absolute power to a centralized
authority to to basically manage
identity so that we at least know what
is real and what isn't real and so all
this push right towards censorship uh
towards uh fact checking all this stuff
that's been going on that's been buzzing
around in the internet was just a
prelude for what's coming because you
know
what's coming is is really exactly the
problem of not even knowing if the
picture you're seeing is something that
happened and that's coming super fast
now what are we going to do about that
we're going to call we're going to ask
for our governments we're going to plead
for our governments to please come in
and prevent this chaos and in doing that
we will be inviting all the other
censorship as well because all this
stuff is going in the same direction and
so we you know there'll be and there'll
be a necessary necessary ideological
aspect
to the movement towards digital ID
because those that will be in charge of
it are already
like that they're already in terms of
digital ID I just saw an ad today from
the Quebec government
we're from the Quebec government uh
where there's a like a police officer
dressed in pink which already tells you
a lot of what's going on there's a guy
that comes up to her and he's wearing he
has something covering his face like a
and it's like a profile and it's a snake
or something and then she says oh you're
dressing up as a snake to be
intimidating are you like you're trying
to intimidate everybody as you're
dressed up as a snake and the guy says
say yeah like what what's that to you
and so the pink police officer removes
the profile to show his real identity
and says oh you're not so tough anymore
are you once we revealed your real
identity and it's like yeah
that's where we're going that's
inevitable and you know
yeah and I don't see a way out of it you
know I don't see a way out of it because
it's
because people will take advantage of of
the of the AI to create way more chaos
and so you know I mean
right the question is the question is
almost becoming like when do we when do
we run into the woods right like when do
we completely disconnect from this I
don't think it's yet but
there might come a time where there'll
be no choice because the all the
Alternatives will be
uh will be moving towards towards a kind
of Madness of control or like a chaos so
so anyway so sorry I don't want to end
on the on a very dire note but I just
want to say that you know the the stuff
that I'm with that if you watch my video
the ones on the Book of Enoch the ones
on The Mark of Cain all these videos
about technology and about Kane
um
you'll find clues in there to kind of
help you understand the situation of
what is happening now and uh and uh
what's coming in the future so thanks
everyone for your support I hope you
enjoy the new website I've been really
excited to see it flourish and to see it
kind of come together
um and so I I've been on I go on the
Forum I read your posts you know I even
comment on some of them like some of
them and so it's really become the place
where I try to involve with people with
the symbolic world we could say so
everybody thanks for your support thanks
for everything and uh yeah talk to you
very soon bye-bye